[Música]
saludos en directo América de Francia 24
mar pues empezamos un poco tarde porque
estamos como interrumpiendo nuestra
programación habitual con estos
discursos de la ONU Pero bueno ya
entramos en materia vamos a empezar con
las palabras del presidente de Estados
Unidos que hablar el día de mañana Por
supuesto en esta asamblea de la ONU Joe
biden dijo que la pandemia ya terminó Sí
vamos a ver qué dice mañana cuando
hablen la asamblea pero digamos nos
referimos a las palabras que dijo el
domingo en la noche en una entrevista
con la cadena CVS escuchemos Cuáles
fueron las palabras que hemos
reproducido
todavía tenemos un problema con el Kobe
19 todavía tenemos mucho trabajo por
delante pero la pandemia ha terminado si
te das cuenta nadie usa tapabocas todo
el mundo parece estar en buena forma
creo que las cosas están cambiando
Más allá de que la gente no lleve
mascarillas o de que se vean en buena
forma sabiendo que eso no son conceptos
muy científicos quería recordar también
que hace pues aproximadamente una semana
el director de la
omssus decía que estábamos lo más cerca
que hemos estado nunca de terminar la
pandemia a punto de cruzar esta línea de
meta Pero estoy segura de que no se
refería de que ya habíamos llegado allí
claro Entonces el presidente yo vayan se
adelantó Pero qué nos dicen las cifras
de el covid 19 Precisamente en el país
de él Estados Unidos claro vamos a vamos
a buscar esa base un poco más sólida al
revés revisar esas cifras para saber en
qué términos estamos hablando Vamos a
repasar las medias de muertes diarias en
Estados Unidos por Kobe 19 desde que Joe
biden empezó su mandato porque
Aproximadamente en enero de 2021 no en
esa es momentos vemos que empezábamos
con 3.425 muertes diarias solo por Kobe
19 a inicios de 2021 la pues la pandemia
tuvo sus ciclos característicos hasta
febrero 2026 por ejemplo Perdón febrero
2022 A mediados de ese mes
aproximadamente vemos que todavía
estábamos en unos puntos altísimos 2.724
muertes diarias por Kobe 19 sin embargo
vemos que desde entonces es indudable
que parece haberse estabilizado en estos
últimos seis meses vemos esa cifra que
se aplana y ahora hagámosle zoom digamos
a ese a ese momento estos últimos seis
meses desde abril de 2022 hasta hoy en
día han habido momentos de
aproximadamente unas 500 muertes diarias
es haciendo uno de los picos más altos
hace apenas un mes en agosto de 2022
actualmente el último reporte del
control de prevención de enfermedades de
Estados Unidos nos habla de 360 muertes
diarias en Estados Unidos no es una
cifra baja el Kobe 19 sigue siendo la
cuarta causa de muerte en el país pero
sin embargo digamos que esta especie de
Pues altiplano que vemos aquí en las
curvas típicas de la pandemia de covid
creer algunos que estamos entrando en
una fase endémica de la enfermedad
hablando esa fase endémica marque
significa entrar en esta fase de la
enfermedad pues endémico básicamente es
cuando la enfermedad se puede se puede
saber qué va a pasar es previsible no
cuando se puede controlar además con
medidas cuando sabemos que tenemos que
hacer para controlarla pero no significa
que no vaya a ser grave puede ser grave
puede ser libre por ejemplo la malaria
es una enfermedad endémica que genera
muchísimas muertes centenares de miles
de muertes al año en muchos países del
VIH es una enfermedad endémica en
Estados Unidos por ejemplo pero que
tiene unas proporciones muy grandes de
mortalidad y de enfermedad en otros
países o en grupos particularmente pues
desfavorecidos no respecto al covid
endémico podría significar que cada año
haya una nueva variante que creo que
como micrón cause de nuevo estragos
mortalidad hospitalizaciones y que
requieran medidas de control duras como
las que hemos vivido puntualmente
también de nuevos restricciones sociales
es difícil de saber qué idea qué imagen
va a tener esto pero es muy importante
decir eso que endémico no significa que
no sea grave no 500 muertes diarias no
es poco recordemos además que esto
estamos hablando de Estados Unidos pero
hay países todavía donde pues no han
recibido vacunas o no tienen acceso a
los refuerzos hay grupos vulnerables que
probablemente todavía no están viviendo
como si la pandemia hubiera terminada y
además pues terminar esta parte
recordando que la pandemia en su
definición está que afecta a muchos
países no solo uno por tanto un solo
país no tiene sentido que diga que la
pandemia ha terminado quién tiene
entonces mar la última palabra en este
orden de ideas quién decide que la
pandemia finalmente terminó Pues el
presidente de un país como es el caso
como estábamos hablando de Joe biden o
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
claro ahí es difícil no porque cada país
tiene sus propias regulaciones por
ejemplo esas palabras que dijo como tan
ligeramente Joe biden en esa entrevista
no significa que la emergencia haya
terminado declarado finalizado en
Estados Unidos por supuesto tampoco en
el resto del mundo pero es que algo que
hemos aprendido también de la historia
es que las pandemias no tienen un solo
fin Hay un fin por ejemplo social el que
la gente le deja de importar lo que está
sucediendo Se olvida dejan de haber
medidas restrictivas pero también deja
de ver inversión para la investigación o
por ejemplo Entonces ese es uno de los
fines que quizás estamos transitando
ahora mismo aunque de nuevos imposibles
a ver qué va a pasar también hay un cine
epidemiológico que nos basamos más en
las cifras en la gravedad de la
enfermedad en el futuro no puede haber
eso múltiples fines que además vamos a
saber mejor cuándo sucedieron en
retrospectivas muy difícil saber ahora
mismo qué está pasando vamos a necesitar
esta perspectiva del tiempo también
muchos lo dicen como ese Retorno a la
normalidad que a veces va a parecer más
una quimera que nada porque como
hablamos de normalidad de una enfermedad
que se ha cobrado un millón de Vidas
solo en este año no es muy difícil
hablar de eso que ha matado seis
millones y medio de personas también en
todos estos años dos y medio más o menos
que llevamos que ha traído cambios
estructurales en la en la sociedad en la
economía en el trabajo no pero más allá
de esto hay algunos criterios de los que
sí nos podemos agarrar para ver más o
menos En qué punto estamos y son los
criterios de la Organización Mundial de
la Salud que fue quien en marzo de 2020
declaró la pandemia y también la declaró
una crisis internacional de salud
pública Entonces repasamos estos
criterios no tiene que ser una pues una
crisis que sea grave repentina inusual o
inesperada en ese caso por esa fase
endémica ya sacaría la pandemia de esos
lugares Porque no sería repentina
inusual o inesperada no pero digamos que
por ahora esa es una de las definiciones
que tiene implicaciones para la salud
pública Más allá de las fronteras
estatales o nacionales y que también
necesita de una acción coordinada
internacional Entonces estos son los
criterios que el comité de la OMS pues
usó para declarar en su momento el
comité 19 una crisis de emergencia una
emergencia pues internacional de salud
pública y que siguen reevaluando cada
tres meses la próxima reunión es en
octubre pues para saber si el Kobe 19
sigue cayendo aquí o no pues también lo
dejamos al juicio de nuestra audiencia
evaluar En qué punto estamos y seguimos
cumpliendo esto no Pero definitivamente
la OMS es A quién tenemos que escuchar y
no tanto esperar entonces lo que dice la
Organización Mundial de la Salud mar
como siempre Muchísimas gracias mañana
Por supuesto más salud aquí en directo
América gracias